hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about why estrogen
dominance after menopause this is one of
those burning questions that people have
I mean think about it the ovaries go
into retirement they stop working after
age 52 so that would mean that your
estrogen should go down right why do a
lot of women have estrogen dominance and
are at risk for cancer and have all
sorts of issues after menopause let's
let's show you why first let's cover the
symptoms of estrogen dominance anxiety
irritability agitation breast tenderness
weepy depression craving for chocolate
joint pain acne cystic acne weight in
the hips the thighs and the lower punch
in the stomach low libido fibroids
cancer endometriosis it takes estrogen
to make cancer grow in the breast and
the uterus okay now let's talk about
some facts related to estrogen to put
this together estrogen does drop after
menopause okay so that's that's really
what happens but progesterone drops even
more giving the relative ratio of higher
amounts of estrogen to progesterone
progesterone is a hormone that opposes
estrogen it counters it so if you drop
progesterone too far down with no
unopposed estrogen it can appear to be
higher and more damaging okay now
adrenal glands are the backup to the
ovaries so during menopause the adrenal
glands will make the same hormones that
the ovaries do kind of in a little fact
and the adrenal glands on top of the
kidney progesterone feeds cortisol
progesterone converts into cortisol if
the body needs more cortisol that's the
stress hormone from the adrenal it will
get some of the cortisone from
progesterone so here we have this
situation where we have the Drina 'ls
are weak okay low cortisol
your body is going to rob that little
bit of progesterone that you have what
do you think's going to happen
estrogen then it's already high it's
going to appear to be higher because
it's going to be unopposed by the
progesterone so we're going to take that
last little drop of a gesture and we had
and drop it even more to convert it to
cortisol so really it's the adrenals the
weak adrenals behind this whole problem
okay and it's forcing other parts of the
body to be depleted because the adrenal
considers the stress countering stress
the adrenals like the most important
thing so it will rob from this and take
from this just to keep the adrenals
strong okay so basically increased need
for cortisol depletes progesterone okay
so you got that so far now let me show
you some additional facts okay so what
do we know we know that progesterone
converts the cortisol if there's a low
adrenal and there's you need more
cortisol the body will make more from
sucking more progesterone thereby
increasing the relative ratio of high
estrogen okay don't worry gets worse
okay so more facts your own fat makes
estrogen so the more fat you have the
more estrogen going to have because that
makes estrogen and it takes it robs it
from the hips and it doesn't Rob the fat
it just it basically generates it from
the fat okay
and also estrogen makes fat so it's kind
of like a never-ending nightmare now we
used to use something called estrogen
replacement therapy and they don't use
anymore because they found it causes
cancer and they switch it to hormone
replacement therapy which they add a
little bit of progesterone so this was
just Astra dial and then the added
progesterone and then an estrogen
together and then they found that that
as some side effects with cancer and so
they added Provera which is a synthetic
progesterone okay so then some women
take that and then they started to use
prim Pro which is estrogen and synthetic
progesterone together but the problem
this is all synthetic and that's what a
lot of women do for half-life
vaginal dryness night sweats but they
have to realize that there's some other
natural things that you can do and I'm
going to put a link down below if you
have low estrogen because that's a whole
thing that we want to talk about later
we're talking about estrogen dominance
okay so now the estrogen is really three
hormones estradiol s drone and that's
the role and I'm going to explain these
two right here so s drone is the type of
estrogen that occurs after menopause and
it's made from androgens or testosterone
so basically it's a little complex but
basically you can make estrogen from if
you have too much androgens so there's a
condition called polycystic ovarian
syndrome that a lot of people have and
that's the situation where you're taking
you have too much androgen now how could
how would a woman have too much androgen
well guess what causes androgens spike
insulin so again it's a little complex
but if you have an insulin problem and
I'll put some links below if you want to
check that out insulin resistance you
can get PCOS or polycystic ovarian
syndrome from that men when men have too
much energy and whatever it can convert
to estrogen and that's what causes the
the breast tissue in a male body the
prostate enlargement the low libido okay
that's this right here because there's
an enzyme that converts androgen to
estrogen and it's called aroma taste and
aroma taste basically is always seen in
people with with breast cancer or even
prostate cancer it's higher and that's
because the source of that cancer is fed
by estrogen made from this darn enzyme
here and it's converting the antigen to
more estrogen so you can see there's a
lot of different places that estrogen is
being produced not just from the ovary
but from progesterone from the
environment from from synthetic
medication from your own androgen is
being converted so so an ester own can
cause erectile dysfunction a lot of
problems in men
you know like men have prostate issues
right what happens is that their test
their estrogen increases as they get
older and the testosterone goes down so
this whole idea that what's causing the
prostate is high levels of DHT which is
a powerful form of testosterone is not
true because they use DHT to fix
prostate enlargement it's really the
estrogen that's messing up enlarging the
prostate so s Joan is a known carcinogen
it causes cancer and it converts to
estradiol okay all right so now Esther
y'all what's that s3 all if the last the
third type of estrogen and that's like a
waste product of estradiol okay so it's
basically there to help buffer estradiol
because of estradiol is too high you'll
really get cancer and so it's there to
balance and buffer it because s Terrell
is considered anti cancer so it's it
protects you against the bad estrogen
sort of speak okay then we have the
hormones and animal products that you
eat if you don't need organic or hormone
free then you're getting those estrogen
same thing with dairy xenoestrogens that
would be like in the environment you
have pesticides insecticides herbicides
all that stuff mimics estrogen okay and
I just want to make a note I do not
believe that it's the estrogen that your
body makes that causes the cancer I
believe it's from other sources so I
don't think it's it's that your body's
just making too much there's something
environmentally that's increasing and
that's really what's causing the cancer
that's just my opinion by the way the
last thing I want to talk about is GMO
genetically modified foods right now the
big ones are soy corn and beet okay all
the beet sugar and us is basically
genetically modified in the soy and the
corn try to buy food that doesn't have
that in there and plus guess what they
feed the animals core and corn and soy
so you're getting a lot of G
oh okay now this is something that's not
labeled in the grocery stores and the
problem is that when they make something
GMO its modified in a way that it
resistant herbicide okay a weed killer
so the farmers can basically spray more
weed killer on the soy and corn and and
not kill the soil corn just kill
everything else okay as a lot of
consequences the problem is the chemical
name is glyphosate glyphosate is the fat
soluble it's not water-soluble so it
gets stored in your body right now
there's certain studies I'll put the
links below that indicate that GMO the
residue can affect your endocrine system
parts per trillion parts per trillion if
you took let me just give you the
magnitude on it on that let's just say
you had 600 train trucks okay hook
together filled with a liquid of water
and I took one drop of this glyphosate
and I diluted it into 600 train trucks
that's the delusion that you would need
to affect your own endocrine system so
it's very very small amounts and it's
affecting everyone on a massive scale
this long-term studies are not done and
I think that's the most obvious thing
that's creating a lot of estrogen
because not only is this very estrogenic
but this soy is also Astro genic the
chemicals in roundup that are not even
glyphosate are estrogenic and create a
lot of problems so that's a whole other
video but I'm just kind of showing you
there's just a lot of things messing up
and raising your level of estrogen so
now the good news let's show you what to
do about it
okay we took the solution hang in there
I know it's a long video we want to go
organic vegetable we want to do hormone
free meats and there's a thing called
aromatase inhibitors now they use this
synthetically for cancer okay but we
want to use the natural things okay so
you have cruciferous vegetables I
personally use a concentrate because
it's in a pill form and it has all the
cruciferous organic the other
thing is iodine iodine helps lower
estrogen I get it in seek help okay dim
is a concentrated cruciferous
phytochemical and you can get this room
the health of store narrow root is a
very powerful aromatase inhibitor as
well I like the herb nettle root it's a
really also it's good for prostate
issues it's good to lower estrogen it's
good as an anti-inflammatory
now all those symptoms that I showed you
about estrogen dominance some of them
have joint pain and anxiety those are
mainly not necessarily from estrogen
it's from the imbalance of estrogen
straining the adrenal okay it's really
an adrenal symptom just a side note
chase tree black cohosh is a good thing
to take for this condition now if it's
really really bad and you've tried
everything nothing's working and then at
that point I would get congested Estero
cream okay but that's pretty powerful
you might not to go might need not go
that route right off the bat and then
cortisol support why because this is a
product that I use cortisol support this
basically goes deeper into the adrenals
and it's mainly for someone who has low
cortisol not high cortisol so it will
give the adrenals a chance to come up
and not steal your progesterone and I
use that for hot flashes as well but
it's mainly to help support the adrenals
during menopause as a backup for the
ovaries okay we covered a lot of
information you might have to watch this
again I put some links down below but
thank you so much for watching